[Musique]
bonjour je suis Mélanie Vogel je suis
sénatrice écologiste et je représente
les Françaises et les Français établis
hors de France
pour moi quelque chose de très marquant
dans ce rapport c'est que
on a établi le fait que la priorité pour
que notre modèle de protection sociale
puisse être adaptée à la crise
climatique c'était de combattre la crise
climatique il faut arrêter de penser en
silo en se disant il y a des politiques
agricoles il y a des politiques de
transports il y a des politiques
énergétiques puis les politiques
sociales comme si c'était des choses
détachées les unes des autres plutôt que
d'avoir ce qu'on a aujourd'hui qui est
un système de protection sociale qui
majoritairement à 97% guéri des gens qui
sont malades et à 3% et c'est de faire
que les gens ne tombent pas malade il
faut renverser la logique et dépenser
beaucoup plus sur la prévention et la
bonne alimentation c'est un des aspects
de la prévention et donc une des
recommandations qu'on a faites c'est de
réfléchir à la mise en place de ce qu'on
a appelé une allocation alimentaire
universelle qui serait un
positif ou la sécurité sociale donnerait
accès à tous les assurés à une somme
pour que les personnes aient accès à des
produits alimentaires
issus de l'agriculture biologique locale
etc
tu viens pas du tout d'une famille où
les gens s'intéressent à la politique on
n'a jamais parlé de politique quand
j'étais au lycée je voulais sauver le
monde et puis voilà je finis par étudier
la Science Po là je me suis dit vraiment
que je voulais travailler au niveau
européen ça sera toujours été un truc
très fort je me suis retrouvé au groupe
écologiste au Parlement européen jusqu'à
en fait le moment où je me suis retrouvé
être candidate pour les élections à
l'intérieur malgré le fait que ça fait
très longtemps que je suis engagée sur
la question féministe c'est qu'à
l'intérieur du parti je faisais beaucoup
pour qu'on ait plus de femmes plus de
jeunes femmes plus de diversité etc
malgré tout au départ ma première
réaction un peu instinctive ça a été
dire mais que j'ai pas du tout ma place
au Sénat
et en fait c'est avec un peu de
réflexion que j'ai fini par me dire bah
c'est justement parce que tu as eu cette
réaction qu'il faut absolument que tu
ailles et qu'en fait pour faire des lois
qui répondent aux besoins de chacune et
chacun dans la société il faut quand
même que les gens qui les fassent et le
regard le plus proche de ce qu'est la
société française j'ai reçu beaucoup de
messages de gens qui m'ont beaucoup
touché quand j'ai été élu et pour qui
même si j'avais encore rien fait le fait
que j'ai été élu ça leur faisait du bien
parce qu'il disait ok en fait notre
démocratie de respire un peu il y a des
nouvelles personnes qui peuvent arriver
et ça pourrait aussi être moi et ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important
les Français qui sont établis à
l'étranger s'il y a pas des élus pour
les représenter tout le monde les oublie
tout le temps ça permet que les lois
qu'on adopte elle soit aussi adaptée aux
situations des personnes qui ne vivent
pas en France et qui sont infectées par
ces lois je vois pas comment on peut se
présenter des élections aujourd'hui si
on n'a pas un plan pour arrêter la
destruction de la planète on sait que la
crise climatique elle touche en premier
les parties du monde les moins
développées et les plus vulnérables il y
a toujours des Français qui sont là
aussi en fait
[Musique]